J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver. Il y a des sujets que je repousse à plus tard depuis une éternité.
Je parle de ces sujets qui méritent un traitement soigné et qui m'intimident tellement j'ai peur de ne pas leur faire honneur.
Et parmi ceux-là, on retrouve clairement la question des transidentités. Ça reste pour énormément de gens quelque chose d'assez opaque, voire d'effrayant même.
Peut-être qu'il y en a parmi vous que ça met mal à l'aise, qui sait. Et ce sera justement l'occasion aujourd'hui de décliner tout ça.
Il fallait que je trouve donc l'invitée parfaite pour cette mission et je suis vraiment, vraiment très content d'avoir trouvé Victoria.
Un grand merci à Barbara Dupont qui fait le compte Instagram Doux. C'est elle qui m'a suggéré Victoria. Vous allez voir, comme souvent, j'ai été un interviewer très cruel et j'ai posé des questions qui ne sont vraiment pas simples.
Et quel bonheur ça a été d'entendre ses réponses.
Avant de lancer l'épisode, quelques précautions d'usage. Je me permets de rappeler vite fait le vocabulaire de base pour celles et ceux qui sont peut-être encore un petit peu perdus par rapport à tout ça, c'est normal.
La transidentité, c'est quoi ? C'est le fait pour une personne de ne pas se reconnaître dans le genre qui lui était assigné à la naissance.
Ça peut concerner des hommes trans, des femmes trans, mais aussi des personnes non binaires. Et en toute logique, un homme trans, c'est simplement une personne assignée femme à la naissance, mais qui s'identifie et qui vit en tant qu'homme.
Et à l'inverse, une femme trans, c'est une personne assignée homme à la naissance, mais qui s'identifie et vit en tant que femme.
Sans plus attendre, on retrouve Victoria, la femme trans la plus cool de Woluwe. C'est parti. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Victoria Defraigne. Salut Victoria.
Bonjour Guillaume.
Victoria, tu es étudiante à l'ULB, mais tu es surtout militante trans.
Mmm-hmm.
Tu es donc féministe, tu t'exprimes sur ces sujets depuis déjà quelques années. Tu es rédactrice en chef de ton compte Instagram, où voilà, où on te connaît bien, où tu as l'occasion de t'exprimer sur toutes ces questions et d'autres.
Merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation, déjà.
Avec grand plaisir. Merci de m'inviter.
Alors, on va avoir l'occasion de parler de beaucoup de choses, notamment donc en ce qui concerne les dysphories de genre, les transidentités.
Mmm-hmm.
Alors, je vais commencer par une énorme question : comment est-ce que tu expliquerais ce que c'est la dysphorie de genre si tu avais un homme cis devant toi qui n'a jamais connu ça ?
Très bon exercice pour commencer. Expliquer la dysphorie de genre, c'est très compliqué parce que c'est tellement une expérience qui peut être subjective et qui est tellement différente en fonction de chaque personne trans.
Peut-être ton expérience en particulier pour commencer.
Ouais, moi, la dysphorie de genre, je l'ai pas vraiment ressentie très fort.
Ok.
C'était plus vraiment un questionnement sur mon identité qui m'a vraiment travaillé pendant plusieurs années de mon adolescence.
Mais la dysphorie de genre en elle-même, je sais pas vraiment si je l'ai déjà ressentie,
mais de ce que j'ai pu comprendre des expériences de personnes qui ressentent très fort la dysphorie de genre,
c'est en fait tout simplement ne pas se reconnaître dans le miroir et ne pas se ressentir vraiment dans son corps et ne pas sentir que son corps est en adéquation avec sa propre identité.
Et donc c'est une expérience qui peut être très compliquée parce qu'on se reconnaît pas vraiment et on n'a pas forcément l'impression d'être en pleine possession de son corps et d'être vraiment qui on est dans son corps.
Et donc c'est une expérience qui peut être vraiment compliquée, mais c'est tellement subjectif. Il y a des personnes qui vont pas du tout ressentir cette dysphorie de genre.
Il y a des personnes qui vont la sentir extrêmement fort tous les jours, peut-être d'autres personnes qui vont pas la sentir tous les jours,
des personnes qui vont vouloir justement apporter des modifications à leur corps pour justement être plus en accord et moins ressentir cette dysphorie de genre.
Et puis on a aussi des personnes qui, bah moi, par exemple, qui vais peut-être faire une opération de modification de mon corps, mais...
On va en reparler.
Ouais, on peut en parler, bien sûr, mais sans pour autant que je ressente la dysphorie de genre pour autant, mais juste pour me permettre de me sentir un peu mieux dans mon corps.
Et bon, le sujet des opérations est un très large sujet et bon, on peut pas réduire non plus les transidentités à ça, mais...
Bien sûr, bien sûr, on va avoir l'occasion de-
Ça va.
D'arriver là-dessus. Mais donc tu parles de question de confort quand tu te regardes dans le miroir et donc-
Ouais.
C'est à ça que servent éventuellement, on va en parler plus tard, mais donc les chirurgies. J'aurais pensé que cet inconfort, c'est ce qu'on appelle la dysphorie de genre.
Oui, c'est ça.
Ok.
Concrètement, c'est ça.
Mais donc toi, en particulier, comment ça se fait que tu m'expliques que pas tellement, mais en même temps si ?
Ouais. Bah, tu vois, c'est vraiment un peu compliqué à expliquer au final hein, c'est-
Non, mais-
Voilà, belle preuve. Moi, 'fin, j'ai pendant très longtemps pensé à faire une chirurgie qu'au final, j'ai jamais faite parce que j'en ressentais pas forcément le besoin.
Et puis là, depuis quelques années, l'idée de faire une FFS, donc une Facial Feminization Surgery, donc en français une chirurgie de féminisation du visage, c'est quelque chose qui me trotte en tête depuis assez longtemps maintenant.
Et en fait, c'est vraiment quelque chose que je fais pour moi et pour me sentir mieux dans mon corps, parce que c'est quelque chose qui,
non pas que mon visage n'est pas féminin et tout le monde me dit toujours que mon visage est très féminin.
Et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'après sept ans de transition, je commence seulement à penser à cette opération.
Mais effectivement, je pense que pour me sentir plus en accord avec qui je suis, avec ce que je ressens en moi,
certains détails de mon visage pourraient être plus féminins et c'est le but de cette opération et de cette chirurgie, c'est de rendre ce visage un tout petit peu plus féminin.
Sans- on parle pas de changements drastiques non plus, mais c'est une légère modification pour me permettre de, ouais, me sentir un peu mieux, un peu plus en adéquation avec-
Avec qui je suis, avec ce à quoi j'aimerais ressembler.
Et puis il y a aussi un côté qui est un peu parfois oublié de l'importance d'une chirurgie du visage, par exemple, c'est aussi le côté de sécurité dans l'espace public.
Parce que par exemple, le fait d'avoir un visage qui soit un peu plus féminin peut potentiellement me permettre de me sentir plus en sécurité dans l'espace public.
Et c'est la réalité quoi, c'est-
C'est ça.
Ouais.
Donc pour revenir encore une fois sur cette période origine qui était sans doute difficile pour toi, j'ai cru entendre et comprendre que tu parles de ton adolescence comme étant une masculinité performative.
Oui, un peu.
Explique-moi ça un petit peu.
Tu faisais semblant ?
Oui, c'est ça. Ben en fait, le début de mes questionnements sur ma sexualité ont commencé vers dix ans, je pense.
Donc quand même assez tôt. Et à l'époque, ben je me suis rendu compte que j'étais attiré par les hommes. Et donc j'ai fait avec les cartes que j'avais entre les mains, c'est-à-dire que j'étais un garçon qui était attiré par les hommes.
Et donc logiquement, je me suis collé l'étiquette du mec gay. Je me suis jamais vraiment réussi à m'identifier à cette étiquette, mais ben par défaut, c'était cette étiquette-là que je m'étais attribuée.
Et donc effectivement, bien que je n'aie pas vraiment réussi à performer cette masculinité, j'ai au moins essayé et c'est ce que je dis tout le temps, j'ai essayé d'être un mec jusqu'à ma transition, mais ça n'a jamais marché quoi.
Transition que tu as faite à quel âge du coup ?
Que j'ai commencée à seize ans.
Alors que tu étais à l'école secondaire, c'était déjà-
Ouais.
Accompli, tu étais une élève trans, donc...
Alors ça a été assez compliqué parce que du coup, j'ai commencé ma transition l'été avant ma rhéto et donc ma rhéto était assez ouf, c'était un peu, c'était une bataille, on va pas se mentir, c'était-
D'accord. Administrativement ou juste-
Non, non, non, pas du tout, socialement.
Oui, c'est ça.
Au final. Socialement, moi, j'étais dans l'enseignement catholique et effectivement, la direction de mon école catholique n'était pas hyper à l'aise avec le fait que je commence une transition. Mais j'ai-
Est-ce qu'ils t'ont parlé ? Est-ce que tu as été reçu dans le bureau du sous-directeur ?
J'ai été moi-même dans le bureau du directeur, accompagné de mes parents et de deux personnes représentantes de l'association Genres Pluriels.
D'accord.
Ouais. Pour expliquer au directeur que-
Ce qui allait se passer.
Voilà, exactement.
Voilà ce qui allait se passer.
Ce qui allait se passer, ouais. Et c'était pas du tout pour lui poser la question de savoir si c'était OK ou pas.
C'était vraiment juste pour lui expliquer et pour lui dire : « Voilà ce qui se passe. Maintenant, qu'est-ce que vous, vous proposez ?
» Et il y avait notamment l'histoire de la gym.
Oui.
Parce que la gym était séparée entre-
Bien sûr.
Entre garçons et filles. Moi, j'étais déjà sous certificat médical par rapport à la gym pour cette raison-là en fait, tout simplement parce que c'était devenu psychologiquement impossible pour moi de
continuer à faire la gym avec les mecs quoi.
Donc ça, ça rentre dans la dysphorie de genre alors ?
Est-ce que ça rentre dans la dysphorie de genre ? Je sais pas. C'est une bonne question. Pour moi pas...
C'est quoi ? C'est leur regard, des autres mecs, c'est leur comportement, c'est les attentes qu'on-
C'est le fait d'être placé au sein d'un groupe masculin et de devoir être, 'fin, d'avoir un regard posé sur moi comme si, ouais, comme si j'étais un mec quoi.
Oui.
Et c'est quelque chose qui a toujours été dur dans ma vie.
Mais donc ce que tu disais avant, en définissant la dysphorie de genre, c'était : tu ne te reconnais pas quand tu te regardes dans le miroir.
Hm.
Et là, ce que tu dis, c'est : on place un regard sur moi qui est comme si on regardait un mec et ça ne me va pas.
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est quand même assez... Moi, j'ai l'impression-
Ça se rapproche, ouais. Mais en tout cas pour moi et dans la manière dont j'envisage la dysphorie de genre, c'est que la dysphorie de genre, c'est vraiment très entre soi et soi-même, tu vois ?
Hm.
C'est quelque chose de très dans son propre regard sur son corps, alors que là, c'était un regard externe qui était posé sur moi et qui me convenait pas et dans lequel j'arrivais pas à me reconnaître.
D'accord. Ok. Donc ça, c'était pour la parenthèse du cours de sport.
Ouais.
Bon, est-ce qu'ils t'ont parlé des toilettes aussi ?
Non, mais ça a été très compliqué pour le sujet des toilettes parce que, ben
au fur et à mesure de l'année, ben j'avançais de plus en plus dans ma transition et effectivement, ben j'étais à chaque fois face au choix des toilettes quoi, dans quelles toilettes je vais.
Et en fait, il y avait pas de bonne solution parce que dans tous les cas, je n'allais pas me sentir confortable dans la toilette dans laquelle j'allais aller quoi.
Parce que les élèves étaient pas non plus super accueillantes ?
Si, globalement, les élèves m'ont plutôt soutenu. Franchement, les élèves m'ont plutôt vachement soutenu, mais ben j'ai quand même été harcelé pendant la majorité de ma scolarité.
Hm.
Ça a empiré après la transition ou...
Non.
Non ?
Non, vraiment pas.
Ils se sont calmés.
Ouais.
Mais ça s'était déjà calmé quelques années avant.
D'accord.
Mais du coup, il y avait un peu ce côté de : est-ce que je m'expose, dans la toilette masculine, à potentiellement de la violence masculine envers moi ?
Ou est-ce que je m'expose au regard de jugement des filles si je vais dans la toilette des filles quoi ?
Hm.
Donc c'était vraiment compliqué comme dilemme, mais au final, je m'en suis plutôt bien sorti je crois. Et je m'arrangeais pour aller dans les toilettes où personne n'allait.
Ok.
Genre dans les étages de l'école, là où personne n'allait, je savais que j'allais être tranquille quoi.
Attends, mais j'ai une question super importante à te poser.
Dis-moi.
Vraiment essentielle.
Hm hm.
T'as grandi à Woluwe ?
Oui.
École catholique ?
Moi aussi.
Ok.
Est-ce que-
Est-ce que...
On est allé à la même école ?
Collège Don Bosco ?
Non, Mater Dei.
Ah, presque. Il y avait une chance sur deux. C'était une chance sur deux, presque.
Ok. Ouais, t'étais, ok. T'étais pas tout à fait du... Ok, ça va. Bon. Donc ça, voilà, confrontation avec la direction.
Hm hm.
Après ça, tu disais que c'est resté compliqué, donc surtout socialement, mais plus par rapport aux élèves ou bien les profs, le staff, ça restait-
Les profs, il y avait de tout.
Ok.
Il y avait de tout. Il y avait tant des profs qui n'arrivaient pas à m'appeler Victoria que des profs qui s'étaient érigés en tant que mes grands défendeurs et qui vraiment portaient ma transidentité vraiment à...
À bras-le-corps.
À bras-le-corps et vraiment me défendaient auprès de la direction, auprès des autres profs. Et vraiment, je me rappelle notamment de ma prof d'histoire qui était, qui était incroyable, prof d'histoire vraiment
et qui avait vraiment, c'était une prof très neutre qui n'avait vraiment aucun favori.
Et moi en fait, la direction m'avait interdit d'écrire Victoria sur les interros parce que c'était pas mon prénom légal.
Et donc la solution qui avait été trouvée, c'est que je n'écrive pas de prénom et donc j'écrive juste mon nom de famille Defraigne. Et-
Ton numéro de classe, un truc comme ça.
Oui voilà, mais pas mon prénom quoi.
Ouais.
Pas le droit. Et donc cette prof d'histoire en question, à chaque fois qu'elle me remettait mes copies, elle avait écrit en rouge Victoria.
Ok.
Et à chaque fois qu'elle me tendait ma copie, elle me disait : « T'as encore oublié d'écrire ton nom ».
Oh, c'est chou.
Et c'était une petite chose, c'est vraiment pas grand-chose, mais ça me permettait de me sentir vraiment en sécurité dans sa classe quoi.
Mh. Mh.
Et voilà, j'ai vraiment eu de la chance d'avoir des... mes camarades de classe qui m'ont vraiment bien soutenu.
Mh. Ok, donc tu as pu cesser de performer cette masculinité qui était-
Exactement.
-active. Est-ce que la féminité, tu l'appellerais aussi performative ou bien est-ce que c'est devenu vraiment quelque chose de complètement naturel, c'est intuitif, c'est smooth ?
Ben justement par rapport à ce que je te disais tout à l'heure, je considère avoir essayé d'être un mec jusqu'à ma transition-
Mh.
-et de n'y être jamais arrivé. Bah en quelque sorte, je considère avoir, après ma transition, essayé d'être une femme et de n'y être non plus jamais arrivée, tu vois.
D'accord. Oui.
Et donc, bien que je m'identifie en tant que femme trans, c'est, 'fin voilà, c'est l'identité dans laquelle je me sens la plus à l'aise.
Je sais au fond de moi que j'ai arrêté d'essayer de me coller un genre.
Ok.
C'est plus quelque chose qui m'intéresse. En fait, je veux être reconnue en tant que personne, en tant qu'être humain.
C'est pas central dans qui tu es.
Donc voilà, bien que je me sente la plus en adéquation avec cette identité de femme trans-
Mh.
j'ai arrêté d'essayer de performer en fait cette féminité justement. Et ça m'a permis aussi d'une certaine manière d'accepter ma masculinité aussi quoi, et de
peut-être trouver un plus grand équilibre entre masculin et féminin.
Oui, c'est ça. Oui, parce qu'effectivement, souvent... Bon alors, c'est évidemment très différent, les parcours entre les hommes trans, les femmes trans-
Ouais.
-et autres. Mais effectivement, souvent, j'ai l'impression qu'après une transition, par exemple, les femmes trans vont avoir envie de vraiment appuyer sur la féminité-
Mh.
-à fond les ballons-
-et on fait disparaître toute trace, microtrace-
Ouais.
-de masculinité.
Ouais ben j'ai été cette personne-là aussi hein.
On met des grosses fleurs partout, on met plein de bijoux, du gros maquillage à fond.
Mais c'est génial au final. C'est génial, c'est trop bien quoi. C'est vraiment, c'est tellement empouvorant que...
Non, mais la raison pour laquelle je dis ça, c'est parce qu'on remarque que ça tend un petit peu à diminuer après quelques années quoi.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Généralement, c'est-
Mais il y a un besoin d'affirmation quoi.
Oui, voilà, c'est ça.
Ouais.
Alors donc tu es donc, comme tu l'as dit, une femme hétéro. Dans le cadre de manière générale de cette société, dans le cadre scolaire, familial, etc.
On t'a pas du coup éduquée comme étant une femme à la base quand tu as grandi. Il y a dans notre société une certaine injonction vis-à-vis des femmes.
Mh.
Elles ont pour injonction, elles ont pour obligation de plaire aux hommes. Elles sont là pour plaire aux hommes, pour être désirées par les hommes, pour les séduire, pour leur plaire, pour les impressionner.
Du coup, est-ce que toi, tu es privée de ça ? Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu remarques comme différence par rapport à d'autres femmes ?
J'ai pas du tout été privée de ça.
Ok.
Parce que bien que je n'aie pas été socialisée qu'en tant que femme, j'ai quand même eu dans ma socialisation de mec homosexuel le côté où je faisais partie du groupe des dominés, entre guillemets.
Je sais pas si tu vois ce que je veux dire.
Oui, je vois.
Mais...
Rappelle-moi juste cette période-là, entre ton premier coming out et ton deuxième-
Ouais.
-a duré combien de temps ?
Cinq ans.
Oh oui, oui, ok.
Six ans presque, ouais.
Coming out très tôt du coup.
Ben ouais, je me suis rendu compte que j'étais attiré par les hommes quand j'avais, ouais, dix, onze ans. Et puis je me suis rendu compte que j'étais trans quand j'avais quinze ans.
C'est ça.
Et puis j'ai commencé ma transition à seize ans.
Ok. Oui, oui, alors du coup, ma question tombe un peu en miettes quoi.
Bah non, pas forcément. Je pense que c'est une question qui est très intéressante. Mais effectivement, dans mon cas, il y a bien que,
'fin, que ce soit avant ma transition ou après ma transition, il y a effectivement toujours eu ce côté du male gaze et de la validation masculine
qui s'est peut-être même exacerbé en fait à partir du moment où j'ai commencé ma transition parce que
avant ma transition, bah, je recherchais la validation masculine que dans les yeux des hommes qui pouvaient être attirés par moi en tant que mec quoi.
Et après, j'ai cherché la validation masculine dans le regard des hommes qui pouvaient être attirés par moi en tant que femme.
Et donc ça s'est un peu exacerbé en fait parce que concrètement, bah en tant que femme, oui, il y avait beaucoup plus d'hommes hétérosexuels autour de moi que d'hommes homosexuels.
Et donc il y avait beaucoup plus de regards dans lesquels aller chercher la validation.
Mh. Oui, c'est ça.
Et donc...
Façon de valider la transition, c'est finalement être désirée par un homme straight.
Ouais, c'est hyper triste, mais c'est un peu ça la réalité qui se passe dans la tête, ouais.
Est-ce que l'inverse est vrai aussi pour les hommes trans ?
Très bonne question. J'en ai aucune idée.
Ok. Ben écoute-
J'en ai aucune idée.
Faudra trouver un-
Je vais pas répondre à leur place.
Ok, oui, non, mais je pense que c'est une question un petit peu poussée, j'avoue. Mais donc voilà, comme on le sent déjà un petit peu dans la discussion qu'on a eue, il y a plein de vécus, plein de discours possibles hein.
On vient de le voir encore une fois avec la question que je viens de poser. On entend parfois dans certaines bouches des phrases comme : « Je suis né dans le mauvais corps ».
Ouais.
« On m'a assigné un genre qui n'était pas le bon, pas le mien ».
Ça m'interpelle toujours parce que ça clashe quand même assez nettement avec l'idée qu'on ne naît pas femme, on le devient.
Ouais.
Il y a un petit peu cette idée de : « Non, mais moi, j'étais déjà une femme quand je suis né, j'ai toujours été une femme, mais les gens se sont trompés.
Les gens m'ont dit que j'étais un homme, et en fait non ». Du coup, comment est-ce que cette vision du genre-là, de dire : « On m'a collé le mauvais genre ».
Mh.
Ça, ça peut influencer les différents discours autour des transidentités. Qu'est-ce que t'en penses de ce petit clash dont on vient de parler ?
Ben moi, je pense que la phrase « Je suis né dans le mauvais corps », elle est vraiment très mauvaise parce que c'est hyper dégradant pour nos corps en fait.
C'est hyper dégradant pour nos corps trans. Moi, je suis pas né dans le mauvais corps, je suis né dans le bon corps et-
Et aussi donc implicitement l'injonction de dire : Non, mais il faut faire une vaginoplastie, il faut faire toutes ces opérations-
Ouais, c'est un peu ça ouais.
Sinon ça reste le mauvais corps.
C'est exactement ça et je trouve que cette phrase est très liée justement à l'injonction qu'il y avait avant dans les parcours trans de devoir aller jusqu'à une opération de réassignation des parties génitales effectivement.
Et donc je trouve que c'est une phrase qui est mauvaise, mais en fait d'une certaine manière,
c'est une phrase qui est tellement facile pour nous en tant que personnes trans à dire à des personnes cisgenres pour qu'on nous foute un peu la paix et qu'on
nous pose pas plus de questions que ça, c'est dire je suis né dans le mauvais corps.
Et alors c'est un peu une phrase qui est facilement recevable pour une personne cisgenre et qui répond à, ouais, à un discours quoi.
C'est une phrase qui nous permet de couper court à la conversation en fait et de ne pas aller plus loin, de ne pas rentrer dans les détails.
Et c'est un peu pour faire plaisir aux personnes cisgenres aussi qu'on peut dire ça en mode oui, je suis pas né dans le mauvais, enfin, je suis pas né dans le bon corps.
Oui.
Et donc voilà, la discussion est close. Mais c'est vrai que c'est une phrase et j'ai encore vu passer,
en interview récemment, je pense que c'était une femme trans qui justement remettait en question cette phrase et qui
disait qu'il fallait arrêter en fait de dire cette phrase parce que c'est tellement péjoratif pour nos corps et c'est,
c'est, ouais, c'est dégradant en fait.
Genre nos corps, ils sont beaux, nos corps, ils sont, ils sont très bien comme ils sont. Et ouais, moi, je considère pas être né dans le mauvais corps quoi.
Ils ont toute leur légitimité, ils sont pas invalides, voilà.
Même s'ils sont pas dans les normes et dans les carcans cishétéros quoi.
Voilà, donc ça répond assez bien. Donc pour la phrase je suis né dans le mauvais corps.
Ouais.
Si on passe sur l'autre exemple que j'ai donné qui est on m'a assigné le mauvais genre et j'ai toujours été en fait une femme à l'intérieur et les gens...
Il y a presque cette idée que les gens se sont trompés, m'ont donné le mauvais pronom, etc. Là aussi, ça clashe quand même avec l'idée qu'on devient femme.
Ouais, c'est ça. Et ben c'était exactement... la personne que je mentionnais juste avant a parlé de ça aussi.
Ça aussi, c'est un peu un truc qu'on dit, je pense, pour faire plaisir aux personnes cisgenres de dire : Non, mais je me sens comme ça depuis toujours, tu sais...
Oui, pour bien appuyer sur la légitimité-
C'est ça.
Non mais-
C'est vraiment qui je suis quoi.
Alors effectivement, on remarque qu'il y a des enfants trans qui expriment leur transidentité très très tôt.
Moi, je sais que j'ai pu avoir une remise en question sur mon identité quand j'étais très très jeune, mais que j'ai très vite intériorisée parce que
je l'ai en fait très vite intellectualisée et je me suis très vite dit non, je peux pas jouer avec le maquillage de ma mère, je peux pas mettre les talons de ma mère parce que je suis un garçon, donc je dois être un garçon.
Et donc je me suis un peu forcée toute seule dans le moule. Et est-ce que je me sens femme aujourd'hui ? Je sais pas.
Alors est-ce que je me sentais femme quand j'étais enfant ? Je pense pas.
Mais ce que je peux dire, c'est qu'effectivement, j'ai eu pendant toute mon enfance et toute mon adolescence, jusqu'au moment où je comprenne que j'étais trans, j'ai eu une grosse remise en question sur mon identité.
Et c'est quelque chose qui m'a vraiment suivie pendant toute mon enfance, toute mon adolescence. Cette remise en question s'est arrêtée le jour où j'ai compris que j'étais trans.
Mais pouvoir dire que je me sentais fille dès le plus jeune âge, c'est pas vrai. Je peux dire par contre que je me suis jamais vraiment senti mec.
Ça, je peux le dire effectivement.
Aujourd'hui donc, t'as tendance même à parler de post-binarité, à te définir un petit peu complètement d'ailleurs comme agenre.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Je ne me reconnais pas de manière générale.
Exactement. Ouais. Après, c'est pas forcément une identité que je mets en avant parce que je pense que ça pourrait dénaturer mon combat et-
Est-ce que tu te sens un peu prisonnière du coup des combats que tu as menés jusqu'à présent en tant que femme trans et du coup tu te dis
: Ben, je peux pas abandonner tout ça et dire que je suis agenre parce que sinon, je perds un peu toute ma légitimité.
C'est une bonne question. C'est une question que je me suis quand même déjà souvent posée...
Tous ses followers Instagram.
En vrai, je pense qu'on a tous droit à avoir notre petit jardin secret et notre petite intimité. Et justement, le fait de plus me considérer agenre qu'autre chose, ça fait un peu partie de mon jardin secret et de mon intimité.
Et c'est pas une identité que j'ai envie de brandir, c'est pas une identité que j'ai envie qu'on remette en question, c'est pas une identité que j'ai envie d'expliquer.
Et donc c'est... Et au final, publiquement et en tant qu'identité politique, je me sens beaucoup plus à l'aise avec l'identité de femme trans. Et voilà.
Oui, oui, c'est ça. Et ça renforce aussi ton discours de dire que post-binarité, c'est plus complexe, plus subtil, c'est plus un spectre que quelque chose de vraiment homme-femme et puis c'est tout.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Et donc on peut avoir des ressentis, des subtilités différentes, etc. Donc c'est finalement assez logique. T'as employé plusieurs fois la phrase de se sentir femme.
Je ne vais pas te demander ce que ça veut dire puisque donc on va juste rappeler un petit peu aux gens : se sentir femme, ça signifie simplement avoir l'impression d'appartenir au groupe des femmes.
Et ça peut avoir des significations différentes pour chaque personne. Et chaque personne n'est pas forcément en mesure d'expliquer exactement comment.
Enfin, je sais pas, je sais pas non plus ce que c'est être un homme.
Si on considère, voilà, que ces catégories de genres sont fluides, que les définitions sont fluides, etc.,
on vit quand même, comme on a pu le sentir dans ce que je disais juste avant, dans une société, avec des institutions qui restent quand même très binaires.
Ouais.
Ça s'est vu aussi dans ce que tu disais par rapport à
l'école où tu étais, Collège Don Bosco. À rue Saint-Pierre. Est-ce que tu observes qu'on voit des évolutions par rapport à ça ou bien est-ce qu'on voit des régressions ou les deux en même temps ?
Très bonne question. J'ai envie de dire les deux en même temps.
Mais en tout cas, des contacts que j'ai pu avoir avec les personnes qui sont plus jeunes que moi de quelques années,
je trouve qu'il y a déjà une grande amélioration quoi et qu'il y a déjà une grande ouverture d'esprit justement à toutes ces questions
de non-binarité et de fluidité du genre.
Mais d'un autre côté, je sais aussi qu'il y a justement même des personnes un peu plus jeunes que moi qui propagent des idées très très très très très conservatrices sur les réseaux sociaux et donc,
en fait, j'ai l'impression que ça se polarise très fort quoi et que là où avant, on parlait pas trop de transidentité, on parlait pas trop d'identité de genre et on parlait encore moins de fluidité du genre.
Maintenant qu'on en parle beaucoup plus, bah ça, c'est aussi un peu la faute aux médias, cette polarisation, parce qu'on a présenté les transidentités comme un sujet de débat et donc un sujet où il faut être pour ou contre. On a donné, comme s'il y avait
le choix d'être pour ou contre les personnes transgenres dans notre société. Donc il y a une grosse polarisation qui est occupée à s'effectuer j'ai l'impression, avec d'un côté
un groupe de personnes qui sont justement en accord et comprennent cette fluidité du genre et d'un autre côté un groupe de personnes avec des idées très conservatrices et qui considèrent que
une personne transgenre n'a pas le droit d'exister quoi, concrètement hein.
Et beaucoup de gens qui en fait sont toujours pas au courant, j'ai l'impression-
Oui ça c'est vrai aussi.
...qui ont même pas capté le bisou, qui savent même pas très bien ce que c'est une femme trans, un homme trans. Voilà, donc on parlait donc un peu plus tôt des notions des opérations de chirurgie et cetera.
Est-ce que tu peux commencer par expliquer un petit peu ce que c'est les notions de passing et de cloaking qui sont quand même assez centrales pour parler de ce qu'on va évoquer juste après ?
Ouais. Bah le terme passing, il vient de l'activisme des personnes racisées et le terme passing à la base voulait dire passer pour une personne blanche en tant que personne racisée.
C'est un terme qui a été réapproprié après par les communautés transgenres pour, bah justement utiliser le passing comme passer pour cisgenre.
Donc concrètement, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire le passing ? C'est, bah le fait de, très grossièrement dit, c'est le fait de ne pas avoir l'air trans.
Et c'est quelque chose qu'on essayait de forcer sur les personnes trans auparavant
et c'était quelque chose qui était un peu mis sur un piédestal, il fallait absolument avoir un passing, c'était la chose la plus importante parce qu'il faudrait pas avoir l'air trans.
C'est fondamentalement transphobe cette idée de-
Oui.
...les personnes trans doivent pas avoir l'air de personnes trans.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est comme si, bah à nouveau, on revient un peu à ce qu'on disait avant, c'est comme si on n'avait pas le droit d'être trans et comme si nos corps étaient pas beaux et étaient pas justes alors que-
Fallait, entre guillemets, les corriger ouais.
...oui, c'est ça, c'est ça exactement.
Après y a encore aujourd'hui beaucoup de personnes trans qui veulent justement avoir un certain passing, et qui veulent avoir plus de passing et c'est totalement légitime parce que justement, et c'est ce que je pouvais mentionner aussi plus tôt,
parce que rien que par exemple dans l'espace public,
ne pas avoir l'air trans, ça veut dire être plus en sécurité et moins risquer de se faire agresser et moins risquer de subir de la violence,
être plus accepté par notre société et donc concrètement avoir plus de passing, c'est aussi bah, juste ouais ce-
Qu'on nous foute la paix.
Qu'on nous foute un peu la paix, ouais, c'est ça. Et bah, le cloaking alors justement, c'est-
Attends, juste avant de passer au cloaking. Tu expliques que c'est une vision, une ambition qu'on impose donc aux personnes trans.
De manière générale, est-ce que c'est rare ou est-ce qu'au contraire, c'est universel ? Est-ce que toutes les personnes trans de manière générale rêvent de ce passing ou bien est-ce qu'elles rejettent ça ?
Dans quel ordre d'idée on est à peu près ?
Bah à nouveau, c'est très subjectif, c'est aussi assez fluide, je pense. Moi, je pense qu'au début de ma transition et surtout après avoir quitté ce fameux collège Don Bosco et être arrivée à l'ULB,
je parlais pas de ma transidentité, je voulais pas qu'on me colle l'étiquette trans parce que j'en avais trop souffert à Don Bosco et-
Tu voulais juste être une femme, arriver à-
Je voulais juste être une femme, je voulais juste être acceptée en tant que femme et donc effectivement ce passing était hyper important pour moi.
Je voulais avoir un passing qui soit grand et donc, bah par exemple, je me maquillais assez fort tous les jours pour aller à l'université.
C'était, et je m'habillais vraiment très fémininement et c'était quelque chose dont j'avais besoin pour avancer, pour évoluer.
Après maintenant, au final, après bah quand même quelques années de transition et quelques années à être socialement une femme, bah, c'est plus quelque chose que je recherche en fait, parce que
parce qu'en fait à la limite, je cherche le fait d'avoir l'air trans, tu vois.
Parce que maintenant, c'est une identité que je revendique tellement haut et fort que j'ai envie d'avoir l'air trans en fait.
T'as pas envie de gommer ça ouais c'est ça.
Non, pas du tout.
Ouais ouais.
Pas du tout.
Je t'avais interrompue, on peut repasser donc sur le cloaking. Comment est-ce que tu expliquerais ça aux gens ?
Eh ben le cloaking justement, c'est le fait qu'une personne cisgenre reconnaisse qu'une personne transgenre est transgenre.
Par exemple, prenons une situation où je rentre dans un ascenseur, il y a une autre personne avec moi et cette personne se rend compte que je suis trans.
Imaginons qu'elle est accompagnée et qu'elle dise justement à la personne qui l'accompagne : « Oh t'as vu, elle est trans ».
Ça, c'est du cloaking. C'est du cloaking assez violent, on va pas se mentir. Mais le cloaking, ça peut être tout simplement juste un regard aussi, un regard d'interrogation, un regard...
'Fin en fait, on le sent très vite quand une personne nous cloak et quand une personne ne voit que le fait qu'on est trans en nous en fait tout simplement.
Le fait de poser ce regard, c'est hyper objectifiant parce que ça nous met vraiment dans une case transgenre et ça nous enferme dans quelque chose auquel on peut pas être réduit en fait.
'Fin oui, moi, je suis transgenre, effectivement, c'est une identité que je crie haut et fort, mais je suis pas que ça.
Donc finalement, le fait que tu rentres dans l'ascenseur et quelqu'un dit : « T'as vu, elle est trans ». C'est surtout le ton en fait, c'est surtout le « ouh, t'as vu, elle est trans ».
C'est pas, parce que finalement dire que t'es trans, t'es plutôt fière.
Oui, c'est ça. Et c'est le ton et c'est aussi qu'est-ce qui va suivre en fait. Parce que quand on entend ce genre de propos, bah directement, 'fin en tout cas moi personnellement,
j'ai la réaction animale instinctive de fight or flight.
'Fin moi, je suis plus une freezeuse, mais-
Moi aussi.
...y a ce côté de ton instinct te dit attention, je suis en danger et violence peut peut-être arriver, que ce soit verbal ou physique, mais effectivement, c'est des situations où ouais, on est vraiment vraiment vraiment pas à l'aise quoi.
Oui. Alors, je vais te challenger un petit peu parce que donc tu disais juste avant que maintenant, tu rejettes cette notion qu'il faut absolument un passing, il faut absolument un corps qui s'invisibilise en termes de transition.
Mmm-hmm.
Mais tu m'as expliqué que tu voulais faire une chirurgie au niveau de ton visage.
Alors est-ce que ce n'est pas un passing que tu souhaites un petit peu obtenir à ce niveau-là ?
Alors déjà, j'adore les contradictions. J'adore les contradictions.
C'est une très bonne défense.
Je pense que l'être humain est fait de contradictions-
Bien sûr.
Et c'en est une en fait, c'en est une et j'arrive pas forcément à l'expliquer. J'ai envie d'avoir un visage plus féminin, mais pour autant, je me considère pas vraiment en tant que femme trans.
C'est une contradiction, mais-
Tu ne te considères pas vraiment en tant que femme trans ?
Mais par rapport au fait qu'on parlait de genres et cetera quoi, tu vois ?
Attends, je t'ai perdu un petit peu.
Non ? Ok. Bah, dans le sens où j'ai un peu abandonné l'idée de vouloir être une femme à tout prix et je me considère plus trans que femme.
D'accord, ok ok.
Ouais, on va-- là, je vais peut-être perdre pas mal de monde. J'espère que vous me suivez toujours. Mais effectivement, j'ai ce désir d'avoir un visage qui soit un peu plus féminin parce que,
parce que ça me permettrait de me sentir un peu mieux et un peu plus en accord avec ce que je ressens en fait.
Je sais que j'ai une part de féminité qui est très très grande en moi, mais ce n'est pas pour autant que je vais me coller l'étiquette de femme.
C'est ça. Donc on revient à ce que tu disais sur le fait que post-binarité, on sort un petit peu-
Voilà.
De cette-
Exactement.
De cette binarité simple et donc on va chercher plus dans la nuance entre guillemets et donc ouais, malgré tout une forme de contradiction-
Ah complètement, je l'assume. Je l'assume complètement.
Mais je pense que la différence importante, c'est que tu ressens pas une injonction, une obligation à faire cette chirurgie.
Non.
C'est plus pour le kiff.
Je le fais vraiment pour moi parce que-
Tu décrirais ça comme étant un besoin, une nécessité ou bien un plaisir comme il y a beaucoup de gens qui font, voilà, des chirurgies esthétiques pour-
Se sentir bien.
Je pense que c'est quand même, ça rentre quand même dans l'ordre du besoin parce que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui-
Tu te sens mal quand tu te regardes dans le miroir ?
Ouais, c'est ça. Et qui en fait peut-être maintenant qu'on en parle et maintenant que justement, tu me poses un peu toutes ces questions un peu challengeantes, peut-être que c'est un peu une forme de dysphorie de genre ouais.
Ok.
Parce que parfois, je me reconnais pas quoi ouais.
Bah voilà, on est-
Eh ben voilà.
On est arrivés à la réponse de la première question.
Exactement.
Ça aura mis un petit peu de temps, mais on y est arrivés. En termes de langage-
Mmm-hmm.
On a évidemment surtout parlé de la communauté trans jusqu'à présent. Dans les communautés LGBT au sens large, on parle des lesbiennes, on parle des homosexuels, on ne parle pas des trans.
Tu n'aimes pas qu'on dise les trans. Alors qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on peut dire les lesbiennes, on peut dire les homosexuels, on ne peut pas dire les trans ?
Bah si, on peut le dire, mais pour autant que ce soit bien intentionné quoi.
C'est ça.
C'est ça qui est important, hyper important et c'est pour ça que moi, j'essaie toujours, en termes de langage, de toujours rappeler aux gens d'utiliser le mot personne avant trans parce qu'il y a-
Si je disais les personnes lesbiennes, ça pue un peu quand même.
Ouais, je sais pas, moi, je préfère quand même.
Ok.
Je préfère quand même.
D'accord. Oui oui, bon après, c'est vraiment, c'est largement subjectif quoi.
Oui oui oui, c'est ça et c'est vraiment le côté d'intention aussi qui compte. Moi, je parle des trans tout le temps-
Oui oui bon après c'est-
En tant que personne concernée, je me le permets. Et puis j'aime bien aussi être un peu dans la provoc'.
Mmm-hmm.
En tout cas-
Et je pense justement que le fait de dire juste, bah du coup, les trans, ça banalise complètement le mot et on n'est pas obligé de prendre des pincettes et dire les personnes qui sont en situation de transition-
Effectivement ouais.
Les trans voilà.
Ouais ouais ouais ouais. C'est ça.
Bon voilà, là, j'ai un peu donné mon avis à travers cette question. Mais on s'en fout. J'ai remarqué ça et je me posais la question.
Tu as ouvert la voie, donc on en a parlé de ton arrivée à l'université où tu essayais un petit peu de faire du passing finalement.
Mmm-hmm.
Tu as ouvert la voie des baptêmes des étudiants trans. T'es un peu la première. Est-ce que c'est juste de dire ça ? À l'ULB.
Je pense pas être la première personne trans baptisée, mais je pense être la première personne trans à avoir fait son baptême en ayant déjà entamé sa transition.
Ah oui, oui oui d'accord oui.
Parce que je me dis, dans toutes les personnes baptisées, il y a bien des personnes qui ont dû faire une transition un peu plus tard quoi.
Mmm.
Mais effectivement, moi, j'avais déjà fait ma transition et, en tout cas à l'ULB, j'étais un peu devenue un phénomène quoi.
Donc le bizutage était rempli de transphobie ?
Non. Ah non non non, pas du tout hein. Ah non, pas du tout. Moi, le baptême, c'était une des meilleures expériences de ma vie hein.
Généralement, on retrouve des vieux trucs bien sexistes.
Oui.
Voilà.
Oui oui effectivement, mais bon, après, j'ai bien choisi le cercle dans lequel j'ai fait mon baptême. Et comme je dis toujours, j'aurais jamais fait mon baptême ailleurs que dans ce cercle-là, le Cercle des sciences pour le mentionner.
T'es pas intéressé ?
Non. J'aurais jamais fait mon baptême à Solvay, et j'étais en polytech à l'époque et j'aurais jamais fait mon baptême en polytech non plus.
Tu l'as fait au Cercle des sciences du coup.
Je l'ai fait au Cercle des sciences et c'était vraiment, mais ouais, une des meilleures expériences de ma vie, si pas la meilleure expérience de ma vie.
Et je dis toujours que je serais pas là où j'en suis aujourd'hui si j'avais pas fait mon baptême quoi.
La meilleure expérience de ta vie ?
Franchement ouais.
Ok. C'est quoi ? C'est beaucoup de fun ou...
C'est beaucoup de fun, c'est...
L'inclusion dans une communauté étudiante.
Exactement, c'est tisser des liens et puis c'est surtout, moi, ça m'a permis aussi de sortir de Woluwe en fait, tout simplement, ça m'a libérée de Woluwe en fait. Parce que...
Je sais pas si beaucoup de gens vont comprendre, mais oui.
Ouais, c'est peut-être un peu une private joke. Mais ça m'a permis de rencontrer des personnes qui avaient évolué en dehors de Woluwe et...
Mmm-hmm.
Et c'est...
Ça existe.
Ça existe et, et ouais, c'était un peu
la première fois pour moi que je rencontrais des personnes qui étaient
hyper féministes, qui étaient hyper de gauche, qui avaient des idées politiques, enfin, qui étaient déjà politisées, qui avaient des idées politiques qui étaient très installées.
Et en fait, moi, en tant que femme trans qui venait de Woluwe, moi, je me disais que j'étais hyper ouverte d'esprit parce que j'étais trans.
Je pensais que j'étais hyper ouverte d'esprit. Et en fait, toutes ces rencontres à travers le baptême m'ont fait me rendre compte à quel point j'étais pas du tout ouverte d'esprit à l'époque quoi.
Vis-à-vis de quoi par exemple ?
Bah j'étais hyper raciste, j'étais hyper homophobe, j'étais hyper validiste.
Mais au moins, t'assumes.
Ouais, ben bien sûr que j'assume et il faut assumer. Mais c'est vraiment, je me suis pris un peu un coup dans la tronche quoi, de me rendre compte qu'en fait, j'étais hyper problématique.
Attends, et en quoi est-ce que l'expérience du baptême t'a permis de déconstruire le racisme en toi ? C'est...
Ben via les rencontres en fait, via les personnes que j'ai rencontrées à travers le baptême...
D'accord.
...qui m'ont permis, ben justement, de m'ouvrir l'esprit, mais enfin puissance dix mille quoi.
T'as fait du, entre guillemets, du cloaking pour les personnes racisées ou quoi ? Oui, t'as...
Non, mais j'ai rien fait de grave hein. J'ai rien fait de grave, mais non, j'aurais jamais tenu des propos pareils, mais je sais pas...
Genre un jour, ça, c'est l'exemple où je me suis vraiment pris une claque dans la...
Oui.
...dans la tête. C'est...
T'es vraiment pas obligée hein, si ça...
Non, non, mais ça...
Si t'assumes pas.
...non, non, j'assume complètement. C'est, ben j'ai rencontré notamment des personnes diabétiques.
Ok, je suis diabétique.
Ah ouais ?
Vas-y.
Ok.
Choque-moi.
Eh ben, et je lui ai dit un jour : « Ben au moins moi, mon pancréas, il fonctionne ».
Oui, mais c'était une blague.
Oui, c'était une blague, mais c'est hyper problématique. Enfin, c'est horrible. Je me suis vraiment...
Non mais l'humour noir, c'est-- tant que c'est pas pensé, ça va.
Mais est-ce que c'était pas pensé, tu vois ?
Ah, je sais pas.
J'en sais rien. J'en sais rien, mais c'est juste qu'en tout cas, ce jour-là, ma pote diabétique m'a vraiment un peu remonté les bretelles et elle était en mode : « Mais Vic, on dit pas ça ».
Mh.
Et je, c'est vraiment, je me suis pris un coup...
Est-ce que le but, c'est de choquer, de créer un petit malaise et puis finalement, on rigole et tu le penses pas vraiment, ou bien est-ce que le but, c'est de la faire sentir mal dans sa peau quoi ? C'est ça...
Ben il y avait pas de but. C'était juste, ouais, c'était une petite blague quoi. Mais je m'étais pas rendu compte que la blague pouvait être mal perçue.
Mh.
Et qu'effectivement, c'était un peu validiste quand même quoi.
Un peu clueless. Peut-être, tu te rendais même pas compte que c'était un peu violent.
Non, je me rendais pas compte. Et elle m'a permis de me faire me rendre compte que ouais, c'était quand même... pouf quoi.
Ok.
Et ça, c'était vraiment, c'est ce jour-là où je me suis pris vraiment une claque et où je me suis dit : « Vic, purée, il faut quand même que tu te remettes en question quoi ».
J'ai une expérience avec quelqu'un un jour qui se baladait avec un tout petit sac et quelqu'un faisait une blague en disant : « On dirait qu'il est diabétique », parce que voilà, il y a des gens qui se baladent avec une pompe.
Ok. Mh.
Et donc tout le monde se marre. Et puis à un moment donné, elle me regarde, elle fait : « Putain, c'est vrai que Guillaume, il est diabétique ».
Bon, j'ai pas de pompe hein, mais ça va.
Mh.
Et tout d'un coup, elle s'est genre excusée, aplatie, genre : « Oh pardon, pardon ».
Et en fait, la blague était très bien.
Mh.
Mais le fait qu'elle ait l'impression de me faire du mal en disant ça, je me suis dit : « Ah peut-être que la blague était peut-être pas si sympa que ça ».
Ouais. Ouais, ouais.
Donc c'est, ouais, c'est large, c'est très subtil hein, tout ça. C'est un peu une question de...
Oui, c'est hyper subtil, mais...
...sur l'intention.
Mais ça m'a permis vraiment d'entamer un gros processus de déconstruction en fait, tout simplement, de déconstruction de toutes les idées reçues que j'avais pu recevoir de
cette éducation, dans le carcan de Woluwe quoi, dans
C'est là qu'on t'a appris à faire des blagues sur les diabétiques ?
Ben je pense que ouais, un peu inconsciemment, c'est à travers ma socialisation dans un milieu qui est très fermé, qui est très bourgeois, qui est très blanc, qui est très homophobe. Ouais...
Donc je suis d'accord que Woluwe, c'est Woluwe, mais je pense que c'est pas tellement mieux ailleurs.
C'est vrai, c'est vrai. J'ai un peu tendance à beaucoup cracher sur Woluwe, mais...
Laissons Woluwe tranquille. Make Woluwe great again. OK. Donc ça, c'était pour la question des baptêmes. Aujourd'hui, tu sais s'il y a beaucoup d'étudiantes, étudiants trans qui font des baptêmes ?
Ouais.
Ça s'est normalisé, ça s'est banalisé quoi. Et avant, on n'osait pas ? Qu'est-ce qui a changé à ce niveau-là ?
Ben il y a eu une grosse remise en question de
Comité ?
...de tout le milieu qu'on appelle le folklore à l'ULB, c'est-à-dire, ben toutes les personnes baptisées qui sont actives dans les cercles, ça peut être les comitards, les comitards de baptême.
Enfin, il y a eu une énorme remise en question...
Aussi dans le cadre des violences sexuelles et sexistes de manière générale...
Exactement. Exactement. Avec...
...de façon globale ou pas ?
Oui, c'est ça. C'est un peu arrivé en même temps avec Balance ton folklore.
Mh.
Qui, voilà, il y a eu un compte Instagram où justement, on a commencé à dénoncer tous les faits qui étaient dessus.
Et je pense que
ça a permis d'enclencher une grosse remise en question et un grand changement,
dans ce milieu du folklore qui font que maintenant, il y a effectivement, je connais des personnes trans qui ont fait leur baptême après moi quoi.
Super.
Et...
Et donc là où avant, malgré tout, tu dirais, c'était quand même un peu un champ de mines, c'était un peu, on n'osait pas, terrain dangereux, potentiellement ?
Oui, c'est-- ben en fait, on n'en parlait pas, tout simplement.
Ok.
On n'en parlait pas. Moi, je sais que pour en avoir discuté avec mon président de baptême,
à qui je fais des gros bisous si jamais il nous écoute, que lui, dans sa tête, il avait déjà préparé le baptême pour accueillir une personne trans au sein du baptême, mais il pensait pas qu'il le vivrait en tant qu'étudiant.
Il pensait que ça arriverait plus tard.
Deux générations après, pour ses petits-enfants.
Non, peut-être pas à ce point-là, mais au moins quelques années plus tard quoi.
C'est ça, oui. Ok.
Et puis du coup, ben moi, j'ai débarqué en mode : « Coucou ».
Ok, donc il avait anticipé.
Et ouais, et vraiment, tout s'est très bien passé. Et c'est juste qu'effectivement, après, par la suite, c'est devenu une rumeur dans tout le milieu du folklore, justement, qu'il y a une meuf trans baptisée au CDS quoi.
Et donc le passing dont tu rêvais à ce moment-là, ça marchait pas trop ?
Ouais, ben je l'avais déjà un peu laissé tomber, le passing, à ce moment-là, parce qu'on m'avait-- il y avait déjà une personne qui s'était crue intéressante en Polytech à dire à tout le monde que j'étais trans.
Et donc j'étais déjà la meuf trans en Polytech.
Mh.
Et après, j'ai fait mon baptême et je suis devenue la meuf trans dans tout le folklore quoi, à l'ULB. Et donc c'est ça en fait un peu qui m'a poussée à mon activisme aussi hein, parce que,
ben en fait, j'en avais marre de plus pouvoir rencontrer une personne sans qu'elle ait entendu parler de moi à l'ULB, tout simplement. Et donc
je me suis dit : « Quitte à ce que tout le monde parle de moi à l'ULB, eh ben je vais leur donner une raison et je vais leur donner du matériel pour discuter correctement des transidentités et pour
avoir des vraies conversations plutôt que juste utiliser mon identité comme un bruit de couloir et comme des rumeurs intéressantes quoi ».
Mh. Mh. Mh. Ok, mais donc les choses avancent vers le mieux, en tout cas au niveau de l'ULB, des comités, du folklore, comme on disait.
C'est pas le cas partout. On observe donc un peu partout des paniques morales, notamment sur la question trans ces dernières années.
Voilà, il y a une loi donc en cette année au Royaume-Uni qui interdisait les bloqueurs de, les puberty blockers, les bloqueurs de puberté, on dit ça comme ça en français ?
Ouais voilà. Ce qui est quand même assez... Je sais pas, ça sert à quoi quoi ? Enfin c'est... Bon voilà bref...
C'est de la diabolisation quoi.
Voilà. Donc ça, c'est au Royaume-Uni. Aux États-Unis, c'est limite encore pire.
Donald Trump qui fait des commentaires bizarres en disant que votre petite fille va aller à l'école maternelle le matin, puis elle va rentrer, ça va être un petit garçon, qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Panique morale quoi.
Ouais, panique morale.
N'importe quoi et on fait paniquer tout le monde. Pourquoi aujourd'hui ? Pourquoi maintenant ? C'est pas nouveau les personnes trans.
Non, mais on croit que c'est nouveau et on a l'impression que c'est nouveau et on a l'impression qu'il y a un phénomène de mode parce que justement, on en parle beaucoup plus et que
ouais, on pense que, ouais, j'ai du mal à comprendre aussi un peu.
Je suis un peu perdue face à toute cette panique morale comme tu dis et qui prend tellement d'ampleur en fait dans les discours, dans les discours médiatiques, dans les discours politiques.
Il y a vraiment une véritable diabolisation des identités trans et je comprends pas forcément pourquoi. C'est ouais, c'est un peu compliqué.
Moi, j'aime bien prendre l'exemple pour un peu mettre ça en parallèle et pour un peu répondre à l'argument qui dit que c'est un effet de mode et qu'il y a de plus en plus de personnes trans.
J'aime bien prendre l'exemple des gauchers.
Ok. Oui oui oui, le fameux graphe là.
Le fameux graphe qui, je trouve, est génial et je pense qu'on est beaucoup de personnes trans à utiliser ce fameux graphe pour un peu répondre à cet argument-là
qui est du coup genre un graphe où on
voit qu'effectivement, à partir du moment où on a laissé les gens écrire de la main gauche, il y a eu effectivement une augmentation du nombre de personnes qui écrivaient de la main gauche, mais après, on voit que ça plafonne.
Et c'est tout simplement la même chose pour moi avec les personnes trans. À partir du moment où on a le droit d'exister, où on nous laisse le droit d'exister et de vivre dignement,
eh bien forcément, de plus en plus de personnes trans vont assumer le fait qu'elles étaient trans.
Il n'y avait pas moins de personnes trans avant.
C'est juste qu'on n'avait pas le droit d'exister avant. Et donc toutes les personnes trans qui ont pu exister dans les dernières générations n'ont pas forcément fait de coming out et n'ont jamais vécu
leur vie en tant que personnes trans parce que ce n'était pas possible presque, tout simplement.
Juste pour rebondir là-dessus, parce que je pense donc il n'y a pas moins de personnes trans avant. Est-ce que tu as en tête des exemples de personnages historiques dont...
Je ne sais pas, on parle de Jeanne d'Arc parfois comme étant un exemple de-
Ah ouais ?
Ah, t'as jamais entendu ça ?
J'adore. Non, non, j'ai jamais entendu.
C'est intéressant, non ?
Ouais, c'est assez intéressant. Après, il y a des... Enfin moi, j'ai une théorie qui dit que Jésus est un homme trans, mais ça, c'est trop touchy.
Si tu veux te faire crucifier, c'est une bonne strat'. Et Jeanne d'Arc, c'est aussi, voilà, une figure emblématique de l'extrême droite.
Donc c'est, voilà, c'est des exemples qui sont intéressants.
Voilà, c'est des exemples qui sont intéressants. J'ai pas forcément d'exemples historiques en tête, mais je veux dire, les personnes trans existent depuis la nuit des temps quoi.
Donc c'est pas nouveau. C'est juste que maintenant, on a le droit d'exister et on s'est battu pour avoir le droit d'exister.
Et donc effectivement, eh bien maintenant, on revendique nos droits, tout simplement.
Au-delà de ça, disons que les personnes trans, j'ai l'impression, sont devenues presque des, comment est-ce qu'on dit ?
Des cibles quoi. On va les utiliser comme étant un petit peu le problème aujourd'hui quoi. Tout ce qui ne va pas avec la société, rien ne va plus.
Et finalement, c'est vrai que remettre en question la binarité, le fait qu'il y a les hommes, il y a les femmes et c'est quelque chose qui est pour la grande majorité des gens, eh bien oui, c'est pas plus compliqué que ça.
Remettre ça en question, ça fait un petit peu l'effet du sol qui disparaît sous tes pieds. Donc panique morale.
Ouais.
Donc c'est... Qu'est-ce qu'on fait en réponse à ça ? Et qu'est-ce que... Enfin déjà, est-ce que tu partages le constat que c'est vraiment des cibles systématiques aujourd'hui dans les campagnes politiques ?
Eh bien quand même hein. Franchement, on est visé par l'extrême droite quoi, on va pas se mentir. On est des cibles faciles, mais à nouveau, on s'en prend à une communauté minorisée.
C'est facile de taper sur les personnes trans parce que ouais, on est une minorité, parce qu'on n'a pas tous nos droits acquis et donc on a envie de nous les retirer avant qu'on puisse acquérir tous nos droits.
On est une cible facile et effectivement, ça revient souvent dans les discours et je trouve ça triste en même temps parce que moi, à toutes ces personnes qui peuvent avoir des propos transphobes et des propos parfois
vraiment, on se demande où ils vont les chercher,
j'ai juste envie de leur proposer un café quoi.
Enfin par exemple, Dora Moutot, qui est une femelliste comme elle s'appelle et qui est une figure de l'activisme transphobe, je sais pas trop comment-
Une Terf quoi.
Une Terf quoi, ouais exactement.
Donc c'est trans-exclusionary radical feminist.
Exactement.
Mais est-ce que les Terfs sont des féministes ?
Alors non. Non. Pour moi, non.
C'est pour ça que t'as dit, elle se présente comme étant féministe.
Voilà, c'est ça. J'ai vraiment l'impression qu'il y a une déshumanisation en fait des personnes trans et il y a une déshumanisation des récits trans qui a commencé par les adultes.
On a commencé à un peu nous déshumaniser, nous les adultes trans et maintenant, on voit que cette déshumanisation, elle se répercute sur les enfants et maintenant, on glisse sur les enfants quoi.
Et en fait, ça fait un peu un ping-pong entre adultes et enfants. Et effectivement, les enfants sont une cible facile, les enfants trans, parce que non, mais il faudrait pas toucher aux enfants quand même.
Protéger nos enfants.
Voilà, protéger nos enfants.
Ouais, ça rappelle les trucs avec les manifestations contre l'Evras il y a quelques années.
Voilà, exactement. Mais c'est exactement ça. Et donc là maintenant, on voit effectivement qu'on bloque l'accès aux bloqueurs de puberté aux enfants trans.
À quand est-ce qu'on va nous bloquer l'accès aux hormones, à nous, adultes trans
? Enfin, je veux dire entre l'un et l'autre, il n'y a qu'un pas
et la frontière, elle devient de plus en plus fine et ça fait peur parce que oui, c'est ce que je disais juste avant, il y a vraiment une déshumanisation de nos récits et on ne nous considère plus comme des êtres humains
avec des émotions, avec des ressentis et qui exprimons nos ressentis.
On nous considère comme des objets. Voilà, il y a de la diabolisation de nos identités aussi quoi.
Mh. Mh. Mh. Donc, tu disais, tu aurais envie de la rencontrer et je pense effectivement que quand on parle de polarisation, quand on parle de gens qui ne se parlent pas, qui ne se connaissent pas, qui ne se comprennent pas finalement.
Mais c'est vrai que généralement la solution qui marche le mieux, c'est juste se parler.
Discuter.
Comment est-ce qu'on met ça en place en fait ? On fait une plateforme de rencontre entre les transphobes et les trans ?
Oh purée, ça pourrait être pas mal. Après, je pense pas qu'il y ait beaucoup de personnes trans qui acceptent de jouer le jeu parce que c'est quand même pas un jeu très marrant.
Bah oui, c'est ça, un peu fatigant, je pense.
C'est ça. Je pense qu'il faudrait que j'aie un très très bon salaire pour que j'accepte de rencontrer toutes ces personnes transphobes.
Il y a très peu d'écoute de la part de toutes ces personnes qui nous voient comme des problèmes de la société quoi.
Ouais. Donc le conseil pour les gens qui nous écoutent et qui sont un petit peu mal à l'aise par rapport à tout ça, qui ne comprennent pas, mais c'est juste de parler à une personne trans-
Ouais, c'est ça.
...ça va analyser le truc dans votre esprit, c'est facile à résoudre. Donc voilà, tu parlais de l'extrême droite il y a quelques instants.
Donc ce que eux vont défendre régulièrement, c'est les thérapies de conversion, évidemment.
Oui.
Alors, je vais dire un truc, je vais faire semblant de challenger ça, enfin de challenger l'idée que ces thérapies sont problématiques.
Le genre, c'est une construction sociale.
Mh.
Donc on peut modeler ça. Enfin, c'est un peu ça leur idée, je pense. C'est l'idée qu'on peut apprendre à exprimer son genre différemment, à ressentir son genre différemment.
Est-ce que ouais, est-ce que c'est ça leur idée ? C'est une très bonne question. Moi, je pense pas qu'ils vont aussi loin en fait.
En tout cas, est-ce qu'ils sont persuadés que c'est modelable ?
Oui, ça voilà. Ils sont persuadés qu'on peut-
Explique-nous en quoi une construction sociale comme le genre n'est pas modelable, justement.
Eh bien parce que effectivement, le genre est une construction sociale, mais c'est une expérience qui est très subjective en fait, et c'est une expérience qui est très personnelle.
Je vais parler pour moi, par exemple, bien que je n'ai pas été socialisée en tant que femme, le genre que je me suis construit tout au long de ma vie, c'est le genre féminin.
Parce que quand j'étais petite et que je regardais des Disney, je me suis jamais identifiée au prince charmant.
J'ai toujours été la princesse dans ma tête.
Mais est-ce que les princes charmants existent dans les Disney ou est-ce qu'ils ont plus que trois scènes dans Cendrillon et...
Oui, alors ça, c'est un autre débat, effectivement. Mais ce que je veux dire, c'est que je me suis jamais identifiée à des personnages masculins dans mon enfance.
Plus Jasmine qu'Aladdin.
Voilà, c'est ça. Enfin, je veux dire, moi, j'ai vraiment grandi, pour le dire franchement, j'ai grandi avec les Winx et Totally Spies quoi.
Ah bah oui.
Et euh-
Je regardais, ouais, je regardais ça aussi, ouais.
Et dans Code Lyoko, moi, j'étais à Aelita, tu vois, et je me suis jamais identifiée à des personnages masculins.
Et donc effectivement, le genre est une construction sociale, et on mange des petits bouts de cette construction sociale tout au long de notre enfance, tout au long de notre adolescence et tout au long de notre vie.
Mais on peut pas décider quel genre on va se construire, en fait. Après, ça, c'est quand même une réflexion qui est assez poussée et c'est, enfin, c'est pas forcément quelque chose
que j'aborde avec des personnes qui viennent de découvrir
ce que c'est le sujet des transidentités quoi.
Mais effectivement, le genre est une construction sociale, mais le genre est également une expérience qui est très personnelle et-
Qui est ancrée.
Qui est ancrée en soi. Ouais, c'est ça, exactement. Et on peut pas modifier ça euh-
Comme on change de chapeau quoi.
Non, non, clairement pas.
Alors, je suis vraiment pas sûr que tu vas savoir rebondir là-dessus, mais donc il y a, quand on regarde-- moi, je suis autiste.
Quand on regarde les stats, il y a ce truc qui revient souvent. Je sais pas si tu as vu ça, qu'il y a deux fois plus de personnes LGBT parmi les autistes que dans la population neurotypique.
Ok, moi, j'avais pas ce chiffre-là, mais c'est peut-être des nuances.
Ok, mais donc si je te demandais simplement, tiens, à ton avis, pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup plus de personnes trans chez les autistes ?
Eh bien parce que, eh bien moi, je suis une personne neurodivergente aussi.
Ok.
Et donc c'est que moi, le chiffre que j'avais en tête, c'était que euh-
Vérifie cette information.
Oui,
je dis peut-être une bêtise hein, mais moi, j'avais l'impression que-- mais je sais jamais dans quel sens c'est, mais j'ai l'impression qu'une personne LGBTQIA+ a six fois plus de chances d'être neurodivergente qu'une personne cis hétéro.
Je crois que c'était ça le chiffre que moi, j'avais en tête.
Moi, je l'ai toujours vu dans l'autre sens. Je vais vérifier tout de suite l'information-
Ouais, mais peut-être que je confonds hein. Et comment est-ce que j'explique ça ? C'est une très bonne question.
Eh bien moi, je pense que justement, en tant que personne neurodivergente, on a parfois du mal avec les normes sociales
et on a parfois du mal à comprendre les codes sociaux et que du coup, justement, on va avoir une plus grande facilité à aller challenger ces codes sociaux, à aller challenger ces normes sociales et
à justement eh bien revendiquer le fait qu'on n'est pas dans les normes parce qu'en fait, on n'était déjà pas dans les normes à la base.
Je sais pas si c'est clair.
Attends, donc déjà, les premiers chiffres que je vois vite fait dans les premiers résultats sur Google, bon, faites toujours confiance aux premiers résultats sur Google évidemment.
C'est qu'ils disent que, par exemple, les personnes qui ont un TDAH étaient six point six fois plus likely, avaient plus de chances d'exprimer une différence en termes de genre.
Ah eh bien voilà, du coup, c'était dans l'autre sens que ce que je disais, ouais.
Et alors, ils disent aussi, donc parmi les personnes qui sont autistes, il y a environ une estimation de entre quarante-deux et soixante-neuf pour cent, bon c'est large fourchette-
Waouh
...qui s'identifient comme étant homosexuelles ou faisant partie d'une minorité sexuelle.
Ok.
Voilà, donc c'est quand même large.
Ouais, c'est assez large ouais.
Bon après, ce que je dis toujours par rapport à ces chiffres, c'est que tellement de personnes qui sont autistes et qui ne sont pas au courant que-
Ouais, voilà, c'est ça exactement
...c'est abusivement dur de faire des stats, de faire des pourcentages, etc. Mais en tout cas, de manière anecdotique, on le constate.
Enfin, je veux dire, c'est quand même très fréquent.
Ouais.
Ouais, ouais.
Ouais, ouais, clairement.
Ouais. Et donc la façon dont, pour rebondir sur ce que tu disais à l'instant, la façon dont je dis ça, c'est qu'effectivement, il y a- C'est implicite, c'est construction sociale.
Je me rappelle d'une fille autiste qui me parlait et qui me disait qu'avant d'avoir douze ans et qu'elle tombait amoureuse d'autres filles un peu tout le temps, elle n'avait pas capté que c'était pas normal.
Ah mais moi non plus hein.
Voilà.
Moi, j'ai pareil hein. Moi-
C'est une règle implicite qui ne nous est pas expliquée.
Mais c'est ça. C'est ça. Moi, j'étais attiré par les mecs-
Liberté quoi. Liberté de faire un peu ce qu'on veut plutôt que de se conformer à des règles qu'on nous a explicitement inculquées.
C'est vraiment ça. Moi, j'ai vraiment eu exactement pareil. J'ai toujours ressenti une attirance envers les hommes, mais je pensais que tout le monde, 'fin, que tous les mecs avaient pareil en fait et que,
et c'est le jour où je me suis rendu compte que tout le monde n'avait pas ça,
que du coup, je me suis dit : Ah ok, eh bien du coup, le fait qu'on me traite de pédé depuis toutes ces années, en fait, peut-être que ça veut dire quelque chose.
Mais oui, voilà, je suis... C'est très intéressant, je trouve, comme sujet.
Oui, c'est super intéressant. Bon après, je sais pas s'il y a beaucoup plus de choses à en dire. Donc, tu disais neurodivergente, je peux te demander plus précisément ce que tu-
Le diagnostic qui a été posé, c'est TDAH.
Ok.
Jusqu'à présent.
Voilà, c'est ça. Mais je sais aussi que, eh bien j'ai été baladé entre, 'fin, on m'a fait faire le test HPI, j'ai fait les tests d'autisme aussi et donc en fait, on m'a un peu fait du ping-pong dans tous les sens.
Et puis du coup, eh bien c'est du coup après les tests de l'autisme, le psychiatre qui avait fait les tests avec moi
m'a dit droit dans les yeux : « Vous êtes dans le no man's land de la neurodivergence, mais je pense que votre porte d'entrée est le TDAH.
» Et donc il m'a redirigé vers les tests de TDAH.
No man's land, quoi, c'est-à-dire t'es...
C'est-à-dire que en fait-
Tu ne répondais pas suffisamment à aucune-
Voilà, c'est ça. 'Fin, je crois qu'il me manque un ou deux points de QI pour être considéré HPI.
Ok.
Je suis pas assez autiste, mais apparemment TDAH, je l'étais assez. Et donc le diagnostic qui a été posé, c'est TDAH.
Mais j'ai tellement été balancé dans tous ces tests que c'est pour ça que maintenant, je préfère dire neurodivergente
parce que je sais que j'ai des traits autistes, parce que je sais que j'ai des traits TDAH, parce que je sais que j'ai des traits HPI et qu'en fait, je m'y retrouve plus en disant neurodivergente
que TDAH parce que je trouve qu'en fait, ça m'enferme dans quelque chose qui est pas assez complet et qui est pas représentatif de qui je suis vraiment quoi. Du coup-
Tout ça se connecte à ce que tu disais plus tôt vis-à-vis du genre, mais c'est quand même un peu biz-- 'fin, je comprends pas tout à fait ce truc.
Voilà, exactement.
Et donc agenre et donc tout ça. Et ça renforce tout à fait l'idée que, mais c'est vraiment en toi quoi.
Ouais.
C'est pas, c'est pas une mode.
Non.
Voilà. Et pour rebondir sur, voilà, ce que t'as dit, le psychiatre, on va rappeler qu'en Belgique, la situation est quand même assez merdique vis-à-vis des diagnostics, etc.
puisque dans les centres de référence pour l'autisme, il y en a, je crois, cinq en Belgique francophone, à peu près, ils ont tous fermé leurs portes aux adultes maintenant.
Voilà.
La liste d'attente était de 14 ans l'an dernier. Ils ont fermé, fermé la porte. Et puis, et puis il restait encore le RUGMAN, la possibilité de s'inscrire là-bas.
Et il y a quelques mois, ils ont fermé les portes aux plus de trente ans. Moi, j'ai trente ans.
Ok.
J'ai un rendez-vous dans un mois.
Voilà.
Ok.
Mais bon, je sais pas ce que ça vaut quoi. On verra ce que ça donne. Je tiendrai les gens au courant. Ouais, c'est, mais, mais par contre, j'ai vraiment dû...
Il y avait une personne suite à mon passage à la télé pour parler d'autisme en avril qui m'avait écrit pour me dire : « Mais j'ose pas parler au téléphone, j'y arrive pas.
J'ai besoin de prendre rendez-vous pour mon fils et pour moi. » Donc j'ai fait ça. Et puis le service m'a rappelé genre une ou deux semaines après pour me dire : « Ah non, on éjecte toutes les personnes de plus de trente ans.
En fait, finalement, on ne peut pas quoi, il y a pas, il y a pas la place. » Bon voilà, je sais que c'est dans le programme politique de certains partis.
On verra comment ça, comment ça-
On verra comment ça évolue, ouais.
Mais donc de ce que tu dis, j'ai l'impression que tu dis peut-être que ça va évoluer ton, ton diagnostic. Peut-être que...
J'avoue, j'ai un peu arrêté de me battre avec les diagnostics, on va pas se mentir, parce que c'est quand même, ça a été plusieurs années de questionnements, de pas de réponses, de devoir me battre pour avoir des réponses, etc.
Sans parler de toutes les personnes qui à chaque fois te disent : « Mais non, t'es pas autiste, t'es juste nanana. Mais non, t'es pas HPI, t'es juste nanana. » Et donc-
Parce que tu ne savais pas que c'était une mode.
Ouais, c'est ça. Non, vraiment, un jour, on m'a dit : « Mais non, mais t'es pas autiste, t'es juste intense. » Ok, voilà.
Donc, et c'était une psychologue qui m'a dit ça. Donc j'ai un peu décidé d'arrêter de me battre. J'ai eu mon petit diagnostic TDAH.
C'est pas suffisant à mon goût, mais j'ai pas envie d'aller creuser encore plus loin. Et donc voilà.
Fais comme tu le sens. Moi, je conseille toujours aux gens, s'ils ont l'opportunité d'un peu apprendre leur grammaire un peu mieux, comprendre qui ils sont.
Effectivement, je pense que c'est-
Voilà, c'est ça.
C'est peu utile, mais c'est pas une obligation quoi.
Non, c'est ça. Et je pense que j'avais d'une certaine manière besoin d'avoir... Ah, c'est un peu triste hein, mais la, la, la validation, la validation médicale de effectivement, je suis neurodivergente,
ça s'est concrétisé par un diagnostic du TDAH.
Et maintenant, je sais que je peux un peu me reposer là-dessus pour un peu mieux me comprendre et un peu mieux comprendre qui je suis, comment je fonctionne...
Et comprendre le décalage quoi, la différence.
Voilà, c'est ça. Voilà, c'est ça. Et aussi être parfois plus douce avec moi-même et avoir un peu plus de... En fait, ça m'a permis de un peu mieux m'accepter, avoir un peu plus d'amour-propre tout simplement, de me dire : « Ok, c'est pas grave.
» Et s'il y a des petites choses qui vont pas dans la, dans la vie de tous les jours, ben parfois, c'est pour ça, parfois, c'est pas pour ça.
Et ouais, juste ça me permet de m'accepter un peu plus quoi.
Ok. Mais je suis très content. Je m'attendais totalement à ce que tu me dises : « Ah non, je connais très mal l'autisme et tout ça. »
Surprise.
Mais en fait, c'était un pari gagnant. On avait commencé cette interview en parlant de chirurgie très rapidement et j'avais dit : « On en parlera plus tard. »
Mh.
On arrive tout doucement donc à la fin de cet entretien. Parlons de chirurgie.
Parlons de chirurgie.
Tu écris dans ton livre dont on n'a pas encore parlé, tiens, c'est l'occasion. Les transidentités expliquées à mes parents et à tous les autres.
Mardaga.
Donc aux éditions donc Mardaga. C'est un excellent tutorial quoi. C'est vraiment quand on part de zéro et qu'on y connaît rien, on, voilà, tu nous expliques tout de la base
pour les parents par exemple, qui n'y connaissent rien et qui ont une fille ou un fils trans, c'est, c'est nickel pour ça.
Et dans ce livre, tu écris que les chirurgies ne devraient pas être nécessaires, mais qu'elles le sont dans notre société actuelle.
Mh.
Est-ce que tu peux m'expliquer ?
Oui, bien sûr. Eh bien parce que justement, parce que nos corps sont pas acceptés et parce que en fait, c'est dur d'être une personne trans, certaines personnes-
Ont, ont besoin d'avoir recours à ces chirurgies-là pour se sentir mieux et pour évoluer,
de manière plus sereine dans leur vie en fait, tout simplement parce qu'avoir un, un, un corps qui est pas dans les normes, ben, c'est dur en fait parce que
on est, on est face à beaucoup de rejets, on est face à beaucoup de solitude, on est face à beaucoup de,
de, de, de, de, de, de choses qui peuvent être difficiles à vivre en fait tout simplement.
Rien que, je sais pas, être en maillot sur la plage, ça peut être un exercice qui terrifie, de-- 'fin, je,
je sais pas, je sais même pas chiffrer combien de, de, de, de, de femmes trans ça terrifie de porter un maillot sur la plage quoi.
Et donc effectivement ces chirurgies-là, on, doivent exister parce que,
parce que pour certaines personnes, c'est juste pas possible
de continuer sa vie avec un corps qui est pas dans les normes, mais avec un corps qui, qui dérange, avec un corps qui choque parce que c'est, parce que c'est trop dur en fait tout simplement.
Mais donc, donc tu, tu disais que tu aimerais que, voilà, tu disais même que les corps trans sont beaux et qu'ils sont légitimes et qu'ils sont très bien comme ils sont.
Est-ce que finalement, là je vais te traduire dans ce que je veux dire, mais est-ce que finalement faire des chirurgies pour normaliser son corps entre guillemets dans, dans cette, cette binarité genre dont on a parlé plus tôt,
est-ce que c'est pas capituler en fait ?
Ben, je me suis longtemps posé la question. Je me suis longtemps posé la question.
et c'est un peu une, une question, c'est une question qui est très difficile à aborder parce que elle vient vraiment remettre en question beaucoup beaucoup de choses.
Parce qu'il faut pas oublier non plus que ces chirurgies et notamment,
enfin, on va pas tourner autour du pot, mais notamment, la chirurgie de, de réassignation des parties génitales, c'étaient des chirurgies qui étaient imposées aux personnes trans avant.
Et c'étaient des chirurgies qu'on était presque obligé de faire en fait. Et c'étaient des chirurgies qu'on était obligé de faire si on voulait avoir un changement d'identité légale
avant la, la loi qui a été actée le 1er janvier 2018 par exemple, en Belgique, je parle.
Et donc il y a un, une historique de ces chirurgies qui n'étaient pas des chirurgies, mais qui étaient des mutilations. Et donc
aujourd'hui en 2024, presque 2025, quand on fait une chirurgie, ben en fait, on, on, on pose l'acte qu'avant on nous forçait à faire.
Et donc psychologiquement, il faut réussir à, à un peu dénouer l'envie du besoin, de l'obligation, du, du... 'fin, vraiment, il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses et donc
pour revenir à la question initiale, est-ce que faire une chirurgie, c'est capituler ?
Peut-être que oui, peut-être que non. Mais-
Si ça l'est, c'est pas grave.
Donc voilà, c'est ça en fait. En fait, si c'est capituler, c'est pas grave. Parce que tant qu'on le fait pour soi-même
et tant qu'on le fait pour, avec des, des convictions profondes, tant qu'on le fait de manière éclairée et que personne nous force à le faire,
ben en fait, let's go si ça nous permet de nous sentir un peu mieux dans nos corps et si ça nous permet de, de, de vivre une, une vie qui soit un tout petit peu plus apaisée et un tout petit peu plus saine et qu'on puisse...
Parce qu'être trans dans la, dans notre société actuelle, c'est une bataille, c'est une bataille quotidienne et si on peut avoir-
Il faut avoir les épaules pour la mener, cette bataille.
Oui voilà et il faut avoir les privilèges pour la mener aussi, il faut avoir l'argent pour la mener aussi parce que transitionner, c'est hyper cher.
Et donc il faut avoir tout ça. Oui,
si on, si on veut capituler pour certains aspects de, de notre vie, et ben capitulons franchement, prenons-nous des petites vacances et, et si ça peut nous faire du bien, et ben ça nous fait du bien et ça, et ça s'arrête là en fait.
Oui, c'est ça. Parce que si, s'il y avait une injonction à ne surtout pas, surtout pas capituler, ce serait finalement dire il faut-- vous avez pour mission, pour obligation de renverser un ordre établi qui est là depuis des millénaires.
Ouais, c'est ça. Et tout le monde n'a pas les épaules pour faire ça et tout le monde n'a pas l'envie et, et, et c'est tellement compliqué aussi parce que, ben,
le, le rapport qu'on a avec son propre corps, il est de facto influencé par, par l'image que la société a de notre corps.
Et donc c'est, c'est parfois même trop compliqué pour une personne de, de réussir à accepter son corps malgré toutes les, les mauvaises images qui peuvent être véhiculées par la société sur nos corps quoi.
Et donc, moi, je comprends complètement les personnes qui, qui ont besoin d'avoir plein de chirurgies pour-- les personnes trans qui ont besoin d'avoir plein de chirurgies pour se sentir bien dans leur corps.
Je comprends complètement les personnes trans qui veulent absolument pas faire de chirurgie, parce que ça leur parle pas ou parce que pas besoin ou parce qu'envie, mais pas,
envie d'un côté, mais pas envie de le faire parce que ça fait trop peur.
'fin, je veux dire, le, le, le rapport aux chirurgies à nouveau est très subjectif. Et voilà. Et moi pendant longtemps, j'avais pensé à faire une vaginoplastie.
Au final, cette, cette opération m'a fait beaucoup trop peur, et donc j'ai décidé de pas la faire. Et puis en fait, j'étais très contente pendant une époque de ne, avoir fait aucune chirurgie.
Et puis maintenant, ben voilà, j'ai cette FFS, cette chirurgie du visage qui approche doucement et qui, qui se concrétise petit à petit.
Et je suis très confortable avec cette idée-là. Et voilà. Et une transition, c'est, c'est un, c'est un parcours de vie.
C'est-- moi, je considère qu'une transition, ça s'arrête un peu jamais et que aussi l'identité de genre est hyper fluide.
Et donc en fait, on évolue au fur et à mesure de notre vie, on a des besoins qui sont différents. Et, et voilà, ouais, le su-, le sujet chirurgie est un sujet très très large.
Oui oui. Et donc voilà, si on revient sur le fait que les chirurgies ne devraient pas être nécessaires, mais qu'elles le sont, on a parlé de capitulation, même si c'est un terme quand même assez dur.
Assez dur, ouais.
Est-ce que, est-ce que, est-ce qu'on, est-ce que tu inclurais là-dedans aussi les traitements hormonaux ?
Ouf, non.
Non.
Franchement non.
Qu'est-ce qui fait la différence ?
Ben la différence, c'est que-
C'est aussi modifier son corps.
C'est aussi modifier son corps effectivement, mais je trouve que le moyen de modification est beaucoup plus doux et est beaucoup plus graduel et beaucoup moins invasif, intrusif.
Et en tout cas moi, par exemple, à titre personnel en tout cas, 'fin à nouveau, prendre des hormones, c'était, c'était...
J'ai, j'ai même pas réfléchi en fait. Au fait, si je voulais prendre des hormones ou pas, c'était vraiment logique que je prenne des hormones
et je suis très confortable avec l'idée de prendre des hormones et, et ça me convient très très bien, mais c'est, ça, ça a jamais été en fait une question en soi de prendre des hormones.
Moi, c'est vraiment, c'était la première étape que je voulais avoir le plus rapidement possible en fait, des hormones. Je voulais avoir accès le plus rapidement possible aux, aux hormones.
Et alors qu'effectivement, les chirurgies, c'est, ben là, c'est, 'fin, j'ai commencé ma transition en 2016 et toutes ces années plus tard, je m'approche et je m'apprête seulement à-
On peut peut-être en faire une oui
À peut-être faire une chirurgie quoi. Et donc, c'est un peu deux poids deux mesures quoi.
Mais oui, donc qu'est-ce qui fait que dans un cas, c'est, ça ne devrait pas être nécessaire et malheureusement ça l'est.
Mh.
Et dans l'autre cas, c'est une évidence. Évidemment, tout le monde le fait, c'est banal enfin.
Parce que j'aime bien les contradictions. Non, je vais essayer de répondre un peu plus concrètement, mais je pense que aussi, y a, y a le côté où ben les hormones sont quand même globalement réversibles.
Ok, ça, oui.
Et 'fin pas, pas à cent pour cent, mais-
Oui, la puberté, oui, au niveau de la voix par exemple, c'est autre chose.
Oui, voilà. Voilà, effectivement, mais-
Ou les seins qui poussent.
Voilà, c'est ça. On peut pas, on peut pas, 'fin une fois qu'on a pris des, une fois qu'on a entamé un, un traitement hormonal pendant plusieurs années, en tout cas, on peut pas faire marche arrière à cent pour cent.
Mh.
Mais y a, y a un côté où si demain j'ai envie d'arrêter les hormones, eh ben, j'arrête les hormones, point.
Alors qu'une chirurgie, ben c'est plus, c'est un moment vraiment marqué dans le temps et c'est, y a un avant/après et, et c'est pas une, c'est pas une évolution graduelle.
Y a un peu, c'est un peu un non-retour entre guillemets. Et donc, et donc y a, ouais, c'est un peu pour ça que pour moi, c'est, c'est différent quoi.
Oui, oui. Mais donc, tu, tu disais, tu pourrais la, la, les arrêter demain si tu le voulais. Tu ne vas pas le faire parce que tu disais que ça te plaît.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que ça t'apporte en fait ?
C'est une très bonne question. J'ai déjà souvent pensé à réduire le dosage de mes hormones.
Mh.
Ça, ça se fait de plus en plus. Bon pas trop en Europe parce que en, en Europe, on a un peu peur de sortir des sentiers battus en termes de, de, de traitements hormonaux pour les personnes trans.
Mais le, le, le microdosing se fait-- Il y a de plus en plus de personnes trans qui font du microdosing de, d'hormones, c'est-à-dire de prendre des toutes, toutes, toutes petites doses,
de manière quotidienne ou même pas forcément quotidienne.
Pour des raisons financières alors ou ?
Non, même pas. Juste dans l'idée de, de prendre un peu moins de, un peu moins d'hormones en fait, tout simplement.
Ok, parce qu'elles ont moins envie.
Oui, voilà, c'est une prise d'hormones qui est complètement différente, mais qui, ben pour certaines personnes leur permettent de se sentir en fait un peu mieux.
Moi, j'y ai déjà pensé, mais ben y a un peu, 'fin ouais, pour trouver un, un ou une médecin qui veuille bien accompagner ce, ce, ce type de traitement, c'est presque impossible.
Oui, il faut, il faut qu'ils aient le courage de sortir des sentiers battus et-
Oui, voilà, c'est ça. Et de s'intéresser vraiment au sujet. Et déjà, pour trouver une personne qui soit formée aux, aux traitements hormonaux et qui veuille bien, en tant que médecin, accompagner les traitements hormonaux, c'est déjà compliqué.
Alors en plus, quand on sort des carcans de, de ce qu'on leur a appris, c'est encore plus compliqué. Donc voilà, effectivement, je m'aventure pas vraiment dans ce chemin-là pour le moment.
Peut-être que ça viendra un jour. Mais qu'est-ce que ça m'apporte, les hormones ? Je pense que ça m'apporte d'une certaine manière de la stabilité.
Et c'est quelque chose qu'en fait j'ai tellement jamais remis en question que oui, je les prends, tous les jours j'ai ma prise d'hormones et...
Mais donc, tu disais, tu réalisais au milieu de l'interview que peut-être, tu avais quand même un petit peu eu une forme de dysphorie de genre à un moment donné.
Mh.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas quelque chose qui va un petit peu soigner ça ?
Oui, c'est ça, je pense, ouais.
Mh.
Je pense, ouais. Typiquement, là, je suis, 'fin à part mon visage que j'ai le souhait de faire, dont j'ai le souhait de faire cette chirurgie, comme j'en ai parlé.
Je pense qu'en fait, je suis très à l'aise avec le corps que j'ai maintenant.
Mh.
Avec les hormones, donc.
Avec les hormones, donc. Et donc...
Et tu le seras encore plus après la chirurgie, d'après ce que tu dis.
Voilà.
Espérons.
On espère. Et oui, voilà, je suis à l'aise avec le corps que j'ai maintenant. Et donc pourquoi changer de traitement hormonal si je suis à l'aise avec le corps et avec les effets des hormones que j'ai
pour le moment, quoi.
Oui, oui.
Voilà.
Super. On arrive tout doucement au terme de cette interview. Je vais juste revenir sur ce que tu disais par rapport au fait d'arrêter les traitements hormonaux.
Donc on peut revenir en arrière si on le veut, etc.
Mh.
Je rappelle que c'est un pourcentage infinitésimal de gens qui entament une thérapie, 'fin une transition,
et qui changent d'avis après.
Voilà.
Donc c'est, voilà. On peut changer d'avis. C'est pas pour ça que concrètement, ça...
Oui. Et encore, dans les personnes qui, dans ce faible pourcentage de personnes qui détransitionnent justement,
il y a encore un plus grand faible pourcentage de personnes qui se sont effectivement trompées sur leur identité de genre.
Et la majorité des personnes trans qui détransitionnent, elles restent trans.
C'est ça.
Mais elles détransitionnent parce qu'en fait, c'est trop dur de trouver un logement, c'est trop dur de trouver un emploi.
On n'a plus, on a un très mauvais accès aux soins de santé. On a nos parents qui nous parlent peut-être plus. On se retrouve peut-être à la rue.
Et donc en fait, la majorité des personnes qui détransitionnent détransitionnent parce qu'en fait, c'est trop dur d'être trans et non pas parce qu'elles se sont trompées sur leur choix.
Et ça, c'est important de le mentionner, je pense.
Oui, tout à fait, tout à fait. Est-ce qu'il y a des points qu'on n'a pas abordés qui te semblent essentiels ou bien est-ce qu'on a fait un bon petit tour du paysage ?
On a fait un chouette tour du paysage. J'ai été vraiment challengé. Merci pour ça. C'était très intéressant, je trouve, et j'en ressors grandi.
J'ai même appris des choses, moi, pendant cette interview.
Franchement.
Donc écoute, c'est tout bénef.
Mais c'est magnifique, Victoria. Merci beaucoup alors pour ce...
Merci beaucoup, Léo.
Un petit peu plus que Septante Minutes Avec. Et on se retrouve très bientôt. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Un grand merci à Victoria pour sa pédagogie et ses réponses. Je rappelle que son livre Les Transidentités expliquées à mes parents et à tous les autres est dispo partout.
Elle a tellement bien fait ça qu'il a même été réimprimé cette année. Rendez-vous compte. Sinon, vous m'avez entendu googler en direct des infos sur les transidentités et la neurodiversité.
Je vais vite fait fact-checker tout ça. On peut effectivement trouver des travaux de recherche assez sérieux sur base de milliers de personnes qui ont connu une dysphorie de genre ou une incongruence de genre.
Environ 11 % d'autistes dans le tas, d'après ces travaux, contre 1 à 2 % dans la population générale. Une autre étude parle même de 24 %.
En ce qui me concerne, voilà, si on me demande mon avis, je reste assez persuadé qu'on est bien plus que 2 % d'autistes, mais ça, c'est juste moi.
Bref, les fourchettes sont vraiment larges, les chiffres varient assez fort, mais malgré tout, voilà, ça revient de manière assez consistante qu'il y a une corrélation statistique très claire.
Ça conforte ce que Victoria disait dans l'interview, à savoir que les personnes qui diffèrent en termes d'identité de genre ont nettement plus de chances d'être autistes que les personnes cis.
Et dans l'autre sens, en fonction des études qu'on lit, la littérature semble indiquer qu'il y a entre 8 et 15 % des autistes qui se sauraient trans ou qui ne correspondent pas aux normes de genre.
Et pour ce qui est de la corrélation entre TDAH et dysphorie de genre, parce que c'est plutôt là-dessus que se dirigeait Victoria en parlant de neurodiversité,
c'est très probablement à mettre en lien avec le fait que beaucoup de gens qui ont un TDAH sont aussi autistes.
Encore une fois, faut prendre des chiffres avec des pincettes, mais en tout cas, la corrélation est très clairement hyper remarquable.
Et tout ça, c'est sans parler d'orientation sexuelle. À propos de personnes trans et autistes, j'avais reçu Alistair Houdayer il y a quelques années.
On était accompagnés d'Elisa Rojas. On avait fait un super podcast et Alistair avait parlé de ce que c'était d'être handicapé et trans.
Je vous mets le lien vers cet ancien épisode et vers le livre de Victoria dans la description. Et quant à nous, on se retrouve dans deux semaines pour un très bon épisode sur la colonisation belge au Congo.
Il est enfin là. Je vous souhaite déjà de très bonnes fêtes et je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut salut !